Speaker 1: It's great to have back
on the program Lee Macintyre, who's a
research fellow at the Center for Philosophy
and History of Science at Boston University,
also author of the book How to Talk to
a Science Denier Conversations with Flat
Earth. There's climate deniers and others who
defy reason. It's great to have you back on.
Speaker 6: Thank you for having me back.
Speaker 1: So when you started writing this book,
it was before covid, but we ended up with this
incredible situation where we are now being
held back, in fact, in our battle against
this pandemic, in part because of exactly
the type of science denial that you write
about in the book. And you end up actually
including covid specifically in a chapter.
Speaker 6: What happened was I got the contract
to write the book just in mid-March, 20, 20, 20,
just as covid was Lockdown's were happening. And
of course, I'd planned the book, started the
research for it even before that. And I told
my editor I wanted to save the last chapter
for covid denial. And he said, well, you know,
there is no covid denial. Well, in a way. And so
I watched covid and I will be born in real time.
You know, after having studied science denial all
these years and thinking about climate denial and
anti vax and just watching it fulfill exactly the
steps that the other science deniers had laid out,
and it was all completely predictable.
Speaker 1: So, I mean, where to even start
with this? I guess the first thing would be maybe
let's start a little bit with the vaccine issue.
Before covid, you actually had some bipartisanship
on vaccine conspiracy theories. You had groups of
people on the left who were skeptical of vaccines
because of their skepticism of Big Pharma.
And you had people on the right who were skeptical
of some vaccines because of their skepticism of
anything that is government authorized of the FDA,
et cetera. And there was a little bit of overlap.
And you'd have these measles clusters in some
places that are left wing, in some places that are
right wing. When it comes to covid and the covid
vaccine, it seems to have dramatically shifted
to what we would consider the political right.
Is that perception true? And and why is that?
Speaker 6: You got it exactly right before covid
anti VAX was more bipartisan or I should say
nonpartisan, because, you know, you had liberals
and conservatives. And yet in some ways what
happened with covid is that the anti VAX movement
got taken over. Or let me put it this way,
this was the kind of thing that the anti vaccines
were were prepared for. And it did get polarized.
Of course, you know, Trump and the Republican
Party are part of why it got so polarized
and then it has ended up where it is. Some
science denial is politically polarized.
Climate change covid, some of it is not. But that
was one thing that we also saw, which was the anti
VAX movement morphed into the anti covid vaccine
movement. I'm sure there are still folks who are
anti Baxters in general who are, you know,
on the on the left. But you're correct that
it has been taken over now by the right wing.
Speaker 1: What line of argument is most effective
thinking? Not generally now, just in terms of
getting people to reexamines anti science beliefs,
but just to get people vaccinated? What
are the lines of argument that you believe
would be most effective? Or is it really not
about argument and it's just about requirements?
Speaker 6: Well, you frame that
just right. It's not about argument,
but it can't just be about mandates and
requirements either. OK, I think there has to
be something. I mean, mandates, I think are part
of it because this kind of denial is killing us.
But I think one thing that I recommend in
the book is that we make some efforts to
actually begin to talk to one another. And
it may seem that that's impossible because
facts don't matter in this debate. You know, how
much debate does there have to be? The problem is
that this, like other forms of science denial,
is not just about doubt, it's about distrust.
And that wall of distrust has grown when we don't
talk to one another. And so I think that the best
possible thing we could do to get people to take
the covid vaccine is to reach out to the people
who already love and trust us and talk to them.
Those are sometimes the hardest conversations,
but I think that we have to have to do it. We
have to be respectful. We have to be calm. We
have to be empathetic and actually listen to what
people's concerns are. There's a hell of a lot of
disinformation out there right now. And if it
helps, think of covid deniers or the vaccine
hesitant. However you want to think of them as
victims, they're afraid. And they're all of this
disinformation surrounding him and they don't know
what to do, so just to be somebody who listens
to that family member or friend, ask them why they
believe this, why they trust this source, not that
that can actually work wonders.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I mean,
what you're saying makes perfect sense. And yet
I'm imagining even some of the conversations I've
had with viewers sometimes who say, well, listen,
the new one is hundreds of thousands of people
have died from the vaccine. OK, so that that's one
that on August 24th, a very popular Facebook video
started spreading. And you say to some of these
folks, OK, where did you get that idea? Well,
I got it from this video. OK, well, what data is
the video citing? And they'll say, just just look
at the submissions to the Veirs system, the VA
IRS system. And then you say, well, but listen,
have you visited the website? Anybody can submit
anything. Nothing on that system is verified.
There's a campaign to submit false reports to
that. And then they say, no, I believe that
it's real. You've not proven that the reports
are false. So then where do you go with that?
Speaker 6: I think you went a good way down
the road of where where you go with that
when people insist on proof. I think
it's important to point out that that's
an unreasonable standard. You don't ask for
that standard for I mean, you could, but it's
unreasonable to ask for it for anything else. They
haven't proven that aspirin is safe, you know,
100 percent safe. I mean, that's just not how
science works. Science is about building up
evidence and warrant for your beliefs. But it's
not deductive logic. It's not Euclidean geometry.
You can't prove that that something is safe. And
I think it's also important to point out to folks
that just as you did about the very system, that
it's it's being gamed. They're thinking that these
are good faith reports. You know, anecdotal
reports, some of those reports are coming in
from trolls. They're coming in from folks
who are trying to get other people to
believe false things. And of course, this
isn't going to convince anybody, but it's
nonetheless important to know that the other day
I read in a PolitiFact that the Poynter Institute,
which is a fact checking organization, had found
that zero zero cases of people dying from the
vaccines. So there was not one credible case.
Now, that doesn't mean that it couldn't happen.
It doesn't mean that it hasn't happened. It
just means that there is not evidence that it
has happened. But compare that to the ridiculous
numbers sorry that are being proposed. You know,
I've heard people say that there are ten thousand
or more. One hundred thousand more. Where are
the why aren't the media reporting this? Then why
are you only finding it in the very system where,
you know, you're hearing a rumor from your
cousin there, these would be reported,
but they're not. And yes, it's fake.
Speaker 1: I mean, the problem with that,
of course, is and, you know, we've we've
done a bunch of interviews on conspiracies
and conspiratorial thinking. If they find evidence
for their conspiracy theory, no matter how flaky
it becomes supportive of their conspiracy theory,
if they find an absence of evidence like the fact
that there is not media reporting, it's part
of the cover up and it becomes evidence of
the conspiracy theory. If there is contradictory
evidence, then that evidence has been concocted
and is not trustworthy. And I just don't know how
we really deal with that on a wholesale basis.
Your ideas make perfect sense. Empathy, listening
one on one. It feels very sort of retail.
And I don't know that it deals with the wholesale
problem of the millions that fall for this stuff.
Speaker 6: You bring up a good point here, there
are once you're talking to people who have fallen
for it, it's in some sense too late. Oh, it's
OK. It's already spread, right? Right. So,
I mean, we should be talking more about who's
behind the disinformation campaign and how
the disinformation gets amplified. And I can say
a little bit more about that if you want to. Yeah,
please. I mean, what but once that's out there
in the world, then you do have to talk to the to
the deniers. And let's start with that. It's
it's generally a good idea not to get into a
factual debate with them because their position
is not really based on facts in the first place.
Right. Jonathan Swift said you can't reason
somebody out of something they didn't reason
themselves into in the first place. But notice
a couple of the things that you've mentioned.
They have to do with logic. They have to do with
evidence. They have to do with the way that people
are reasoning on the basis of evidence. And so
to point out, you know, to a conspiracy theorist,
well, what could convince you that this conspiracy
theory is wrong? They're right, because if there's
evidence for it, you accept it. If there's no
evidence, you think that that counts for it,
too. I mean, how do you know that this is
the case? You know, so, you know, talking
and there's, in fact, good empirical evidence.
Now, there was a study in the nature of human
behavior in twenty nineteen, which showed
there's something called technique. Rebuttal
can work against science deniers. All
science deniers engage in the same form of
toxic reasoning. They cherry pick facts. They rely
on conspiracy theories. They engage in illogical
reasoning. They rely on fake experts. And they
think science has to be perfect. And once you know
that blueprint, you can call them out on it in a
respectful way. But you don't have to get into a
factual debate where what often happens with me
as somebody will send me an email and say, well,
you know, here are 20 things that
you need to read immediately. And I.
I don't I don't I'm not going to get into
that debate with them because, you know,
why are they trying to convince me if they have
the evidence, they should be trying to convince
the CDC or the other scientists. Now, they'd say
that's part of a conspiracy. What I always do as
I punt to the idea of, well, let's talk about your
reasoning. Let's talk about how your you've come
to the conclusions that you've come to. Why do
you trust this person? Why do you trust this video
that you saw, etc., etc.? And the interesting part
here is to a group of conspiracy theorists raising
the issue of trust that might work for you.
Speaker 1: Right. And the other thing that
sometimes I mean, this is when you get a
couple of these conspiracy theorists together,
oftentimes their justification, they might end
up with the same belief, but with very different
justifications and getting them to realize
that they don't even agree with each other
about what even is the proof. Like, Flat Earth
is a classic one where the explanations for why
people come to believe it are often conflict with
each other. And it can get pretty interesting
when you actually get them saying, well,
here's how I came to the conclusion
versus how you did. And they conflict very much.
Speaker 6: And yet they all ultimately agree with
one another. And the conclusion is right because
of what they have in common, which is distrust.
They have distrust of scientists, distrust of
the media, distrust of government. And so here's
the thing that I found in this research that
I've been doing. If it were just about doubt,
then evidence would help because you can
overcome doubt with evidence. Scientists do
it all the time, but distrust cannot be overcome
with evidence alone. Distrust has to be managed by
having the person grow to trust you. And how
do you do that? You do that through trying to
build a personal relationship with him through
engagement. Now, that is a very frustrating,
uncomfortable and difficult thing to do. Yeah. And
most people would rather walk away than do that.
The reason I wrote the book is to make it clear to
people that if you do that, you're being a denier
because there is scientific evidence which shows
that everyday ordinary citizens like you and
me can go out and talk to science deniers, use
technique, rebuttal and maybe change their minds.
So why aren't we doing more of that
now? That's not sufficient. You know,
there again, there's the problem of the creation
of disinformation. It's amplification. We've got
to do something about both of those things. But
what can we do every day? Just right where we sit?
We can talk to people who disagree with us, engage
your cousin, engage your uncle at Thanksgiving,
talk to them about why, you know, what are your
reasons for not getting the covid vaccine? We can
ask and we can have a conversation about that.
Speaker 1: One of the last things I wanted to
talk about, there seems to be this meta problem
where particularly in the Trump era, there is now
not even I don't know if agreement is the right
term, but there is a lack of understanding as to
what counts as an empirical claim and what is just
an opinion. And we are very frequently seeing,
for example, when people are presented with
just the the empirical reality of, for example,
whether it was really Trump who did the Trump
riots. And they come back and say, listen,
I just. That's fine, you can believe that
my belief is that it was antifa and they
they think that what these issues are issues of
opinion when they're really just issues of fact.
Is that a broader educational problem or
how where does that stem from the problem?
Speaker 6: This is why we need to take
science denial seriously, because it's
not only about covid and about climate change,
but it has metastasized now to reality denial,
what I'd call post truth that stop the steal
the idea that the January 6th was antifa. This
is a denial, this campaign. It's a classic denial.
It's campaign that follows the same five tropes of
reasoning about conspiracy theories, et cetera,
that I gave you before. Right. That's why we
have to get ahead of this. Now, you ask exactly
the right question, where does this come from?
And the answer is it comes from the folks who are
creating the disinformation. We've got to stop
thinking of science to know as an accident or
a mistake. It's a lie. Someone is intentionally
creating disinformation, not misinformation, but
disinformation. Now, to ask who quite a bit of
it is from foreign intelligence services.
For instance, in Russia, people may not
believe that, but it is out there. I didn't break
into CIA headquarters to get that information.
It was out there in major media in about March or
April. It was about a one or two day story. But
there was a terrific article in The New York Times
about a year and a half ago called Putin's Long
War Against American Science. There are Russian
troll farms that manufacture disinformation about
health issues, about GMOs, about about covid,
about antibiotics, because they want to undermine
the United States. They want us to be at one
another's throats fighting about what we're
fighting about. They've done a great job of it.
Right. Here's the interesting next step, though,
though, that disinformation is then picked up
and amplified on social media and it doesn't
take that many people to do it. There was a story
in NPR the other day that the sixty five percent
of the anti VAX propaganda on Twitter was due to
12 people. Right? I mean, so this is why we've
got to realize we're in an information war and in
an infamy as a country and in an information war,
you have to figure out who's spreading the
propaganda and how it's being propagated.
So I think that in the Wall Street Journal series
this week, I think makes a pretty good case
that Facebook is not doing a very good job,
self-regulating. They know how polarizing
their platform is. They they understand that
they're helping the spread of disinformation.
They're not doing much about it.
Speaker 1: The book is, of course,
how to talk to a science denier. Conversations
with Flattr. There's climate deniers and others
who defy reason. We've been speaking with
the book's author, Lee MacIntire. Lee, always
great having you on. I appreciate your time.
Speaker 6: Thank you so much for having me back.